ça c'est la dernière télé huit cas de
samsung dont la référence est je vais
être extrêmement précis c'est la cuite
santé celle à 65 pouces et un modèle de
2020 qui était présenté aux crs en début
d'année et un modèle qui est vachement
intéressant alors avant de parler de la
télé avant de tout vous dire sur ce
qu'elle est capable de faire pas faire
je vous rassure
à tous ceux qui se diraient mince alive
michaela je ne suis pas du tout à jour
là huit cas va arriver tout doucement
tout doucement tout doucement tout le
monde n'est pas équipé encore de télé
quatre cas là ce que vient de faire
samsung s'est montré le futur sur l'a8
cas sur ce qu'on est capable de faire
mais soyez tranquilles la nuit cadre
arriver doucement doucement vous avez
encore le temps il n'y a pas beaucoup de
sources qui est diffusé en 8k déjà en 4k
il y en a quelques-unes et pas
énormément cette télé va permettre de
faire de l'oeil scaling nous expliquer
tout ça donc vous allez pouvoir regarder
un contenu qualité huit cas ça forcément
avoir une source
8 comme ça tout va bien néanmoins ce que
je vous ai mis derrière ces deux-là huit
cas qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui sur
youtube il ya quelques vidéos huit cas
vous pouvez également retrouver le
service zune explorer dont samsung et
partenaires qui diffusent des images en
8k mais sinon globalement la nuque ap
il y en a petites coupures et en plus de
ça je vous offrir le cadeau que je vous
présente vous avez le lien en bas dans
la description aujourd'hui c'est une
vidéo qui arrive en partenariat avec
robot rock rob rock soit si vous
connaissez et j'en ai beaucoup parlé
parce que fabriquent des aspirateurs
pratique intelligent malin pour la
maison personnellement j'ai utilisé sur
ça vraiment bien et là ils ont sorti un
nouveau produit qui est là dedans que je
vais vous présenter aujourd'hui on sent
une boxe aux offres altesse d'ici
quelques jours
cet aspirateur là il vachement bien
parce qu'en fait et vous grand un très
très très très très très grands services
c'est à dire qu'il ya tous les
aspirateurs robot rov il était très
pratique parce qu'il cartographier votre
maison vous ils sont intelligents pour
la vache sur tout ça vous programmez
vous embêtez pas vous partez vous
rentrez c'est propre c'est pratique
c'est génial mais celui là il va encore
plus loin pourquoi parce qu'il a des
caméras à l'avant qui donne une vision
stéréoscopique et qui lui permet de
reconnaître les objets quand vous faites
passer votre aspirateur robot rock vous
êtes obligés d'avoir une maison en
rangée
parce que si les objets qui traînent il
va les pousser c'est pas pratique c'est
pascal mieux là par contre il
reconnaître les objets il est couplé
avec de l'intelligence artificielle et
comme hockey à moi il ya un truc est
vraiment très très très très bien
jusqu'à présent la seule pièce où ils
n'y allaient pas c'était la chambre
d'elliot parce que justement elle était
jamais rangé et qui avait déjoué de tous
les côtés on voit bien là le côté
stéréoscopique ça s'est vraiment bien le
nom d'aspirateurs c'est le robot rock le
s6 max vais vous pouvez faire plusieurs
étages comme ça c'est vraiment bien si
vous avez une maison plusieurs niveaux
et dave à cartographier toutes les
pièces de la maison et vallières
connaître il a un contrôle intelligent
de l'aspiration fin voilà ce qui est
super bien ça c'est pour poser au sol le
manuel
les câbles le titre ça c'est pour le
lavage et voilà la bête dirais c'est un
peu brillant c'est un mal
ils ont bien bossé et enfin que le truc
c'est sale c'est cette vision
stéréoscopique quand il rencontre un
obstacle
déjà il a touché il va se décaler et là
il va reconnaître les objets grâce à ça
ça c'est vraiment cool donc ça on s'en
reparle dans quelques jours donc invités
à vous abonner s'est pas déjà le cas
ce produit très cool vous aimez les
liens en bas dans la description pour
aller le découvrir et le précommander
s'il vous intéresse et n'oubliez pas
vous avez également le lien pour
participer au concours
quand on maintenant à notre vidéo sur
notre télé de 8,4 samsung commençons par
le commencement
ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver ici c'est
une télé je voulais et 8 k avec des
bords qui sont vraiment extrêmement fin
ça permet d'avoir quelque chose de
vraiment bien intégrés chez vous c'est
aussi un très beau nomme parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est énorme je
d'immeubles c'est pas un meuble mais
c'est le format que vous avez là la télé
avec le pied fait pas moins de 32 kg
autant vous dire qu'il faut être deux
pour le dépasser c'est quand même un
gros bébé et vous faut la pièce pour
pouvoir accueillir chez vous bien
évidemment sans aucun problème
moi le truc qui me plaît déjà scellé
bord qui sont vraiment très très faim
regardez là c'est très très faim d'un
côté comme de l'autre de autant bas de
tous les côtés c'est extrêmement bien
profilée lorsque vous la regarder de
face on voit à peine les bords c'est
très léger c'est vraiment une très très
belle place à l'image ça c'est vraiment
très très cool
ce que j'aime bien aussi c'est le pied
qui est surélevée alors il ya un petit
point négatif et on va tout de suite
derrière c'est le passage de câbles que
je trouve pas vraiment idéal par contre
le pied ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est que
ça ne dégage pas envie de faire quelque
chose quand même qui est beaucoup plus
haut c'est très sérieux et ça pour moi
c'est vraiment un des points forts aussi
de ce téléviseur mais c'est en tout cas
un peu négatif c'est comme je vous
disais voyez les passages de câbles vous
n'avez pas absolument rien pour mieux
faire passer votre câble d'alimentation
et je trouve ça vraiment dommage
là je parle de l'alim il mais c'est
exactement la même chose pour le reste
de la connectique puisque vous avez
toute l'histoire ici moi je suis un peu
mauvaise
quand j qui a rien qui existent vous
pouvez passer vos câbles dans les
espèces de rainures là mais ça tient pas
et voilà ça sert strictement rien une
fois qu'on a oublié ce point de détail
là on a quand même une superbe télé il
existe trois dimensions là c'est 65
pouces vous pouvez faire encore plus
grand en 75 pouces et en 82 pouces vous
en douterez plus vous allez augmenter en
taille plus le prix va gonfler mais ça
je vous le dirai à la fin de la vidéo
d'ailleurs en parlant de ça si vous
n'etes pas déja bonne et je vous invite
tout de suite à venir vous abonner en
cliquant sur le bouton qui se trouve
juste ici en dessous vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu'une nouvelle vidéo puisque je vous
parle de tête télé smartphone une
tablette ordinateur je vous aide à mieux
vivre votre vie numérique et vous donne
plein de conseils d'astuces et de tutos
donc abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas mais le point le plus important
sur un téléviseur ça reste quand même
son écran est ici vous avez un écran qui
est énorme vous avez 33 millions de
pixels
c'est donc de là 8k 7680 x 4320 une
diago de 163 cm un des premiers points
qui est extrêmement important c'est les
angles de vision c'est à dire que
lorsque vous êtes en face de votre télé
vous voyez bien écran vous avez une
qualité d'image tout va bien c'est
optimale mais lorsqu'on vient se
déplacer surtout chez moi et si vous
voyez le canapé et sur le côté eh bien
lorsque vous devez vous déplacer
eh bien vous avez toujours une
excellente visibilité quel que soit
l'endroit où vous allez vous situer à
l'est par exemple je mets sur un côté
comme ça je vois vraiment bien ce qui se
passe à l'image et de la même manière si
vous mais son côté ici je vois aussi
vraiment bien ce qui se passe je crois
si vous voyez vous en faites là on voit
des espèces de traîner lorsqu'on a ployé
toutes les parties que vous avez ici et
là ça c'est dû à mon éclairage qui se
trouve juste ici mais ça vous l'aurez
pas chez vous je pense pas vous allez
mettre des éclairages comme ça sinon
c'est que vous avez vraiment envie de
vous faire mal mais si on coupe les
éclairages on va l'écouter et de 200 km
de rencontre d'un truc ce sont les
filtres anti reflets parce qu'ici j'ai
une grande baie vitrée
j'en ai eu aussi une autre qui est
derrière là il ya de la lumière il ya de
l'éclairage et sia d'éclairage derrière
eh bien il ya un traitement d'image qui
est vraiment bien ça vient vraiment de
diminuer les refait de la baie vitrée
vous allez par contre on passait sur une
image noire on les devine mais ça vaut s
atténuent énormément ici on est sur une
technologie
q l'aide c'est pas du oled c'est
différent une lettre près on pourrait se
dire ça sensiblement la même chose mais
c'est différent on va le faire très très
simple si vous avez un rétro éclairage
led
mais samsung nous a rajouté une
technologie qui s'appelle la local
dimming gold plus si vous êtes coutume
il l'oled vous savez que les oled sont
lus contraste infini qu'on va pas
retrouver de la même manière sur une
télé qu l'aisne
mais derrière vous avez un processeur
vous avez de l'intelligence artificielle
et cette télé et bardé de technologies
qui vous permet d'avoir une image qui
est vraiment hyper qualitative alors
après on aime ou on aime pas comme l
affiche est là si vous voulez mais pas
prévenir la customiser poil dans les
paramètres mais moi j'ai sur les
réglages de base et ça me convient très
bien comme ça vous avez du hdr 10 plus
avec le cantou hdr qui va venir
maximiser et optimiser complètement vos
images le processeur c'est le quantum
processor 8 k qui va travailler avec de
l'intelligence artificielle lorsque l'ia
va reconnaître une scène par connaître
notamment un ciel bleu et bien d'avenir
optimisé par rapport à toutes les
données qu'il assure un ciel bleu pareil
sur de la montagne pareil sur l'anr
pareil sur un arbre sur un cheval sur un
chat sur tout ce que vous voulez c'est
permet d'avoir des images sont
complètement optimisé on a une techno
qui s'appelle l'adaptative pictures ce
que ça vient faire un acte actifs
pictures et bien ça devenir adapter la
lumière de votre téléviseur par rapport
à la lumière ambiante vous n'allez pas
voir la belle lumière si vous êtes le
soir dans votre salon lumière un peu
feutré à vouloir regarder un film ou si
vous vous retrouvez par exemple en
pleine journée baies vitrées ouvertes
avec un grand soleil qui arrivent dessus
on voit de télé va venir adapter la
luminosité de votre écran avec un pic de
luminosité allant jusqu'à 2000 litres
vous avez une techno qui s'appelle le
full led local dimming gold plus alors
qu'est ce qui se passe derrière un nom à
rallonge comme ça c'est de l'analyse
l'image en permanence pour restituer le
meilleur contraste et vous avez toutes
les technologies daube spearing alors
qu'est ce que ça vient faire l'homme
skelling on va imaginer ça comme ça
imaginez que vous avez vous aussi votre
full hd qui va venir prendre cette
partie là de cette image et vous voulez
l'affiché sur une télé comme ça on est
bien un petit peu embêté à ce moment là
et bien ce que va faire votre télé
processeur il va venir calculé pour
venir optimiser votre image pour qu'elle
puisse afficher sur un écran 8 k et
qu'en gros vous ayez un affichage buika
même si votre image n'est pas native en
huit heures alors attention ici il faut
vraiment avoir une source de qualité
moi il m'est arrivé lorsque je regardais
des fois des programmes le soir d'avoir
un peu moins de bande passante
une image qui bavaient un peu ça serait
si tu es forcément à l'écran n'était pas
génial dès la veille par exemple je vous
mets une vidéo qui tournait en 4k la
qualité est au rendez vous ça vous
permet de profiter d'image huit cas qui
ne sont pas huit cas grâce à la
technologie d'upscaling on a aussi une
techno qui est là pour gaming c'est leur
huile games and answer plus tu vas
adaptés réellement votre image par
rapport à vos besoins gagner côté
connectés que vous avez deux prises usb
2.0 vous avez une sortie audio optique
vous avez 4 hdmi deux points dont un qui
est à ercé c'est là où je le connais tu
es tout de suite vous avez également une
prise ethernet vous avez de quoi
brancher tnt câble satellite et vous
avez l'alimentation qui situe de l'autre
côté là bas maintenant il ya un point
qui est aussi pour moi très très
important sur ce téléviseur à parce
qu'il est quand même très massifs de par
le volume qu'il prend dans une pièce et
bien c'est le pied que je trouve très
léger pas emploi il est extrêmement
lourd mais c'est normal pour venir tenir
une télé comme ça mais en terme de
visibilité dans votre piège et trouve
vraiment léger il a ce côté un peu
profondeur qui est très sympa en fait il
est en deux parties vous êtes espèces
d'arcs de cercle là où vous avez une
autre partie en plastique et la
toussaint fixé avec huit vis est très
robuste il voyant ce que je peux encore
plus de recul
c'est très aérien alors ici moi j'ai pas
le mur qu'adapter elle est trop grande
pour mon intérieur et sans même venir la
fixait schultz apporte vraiment de la
légèreté sa vielle a détaché par rapport
aux mêmes fins de poing qui est
important qu'ils étaient très bien
réussi de la part de samsung c'est leur
télécommande je trouve vraiment très
près bien ne vous avait pas grand choses
dessus ici pourrait venir parler dedans
pour votre assistant vocal vous en
prendre quelques instants l'ambiante
monde peut venir activer/désactiver
l'oeil pose le bouton home montée
baisser le volume changer de chaîne et
vous avez trois boutons dédiés
netflix prennent vidéo et rakuten tv
c'est un objet qui est très premium et
qui ferait presque un peu télécommande
décoratifs dans votre intérieur
ici ça fonctionne sur tyson alors taisen
sens
être toute la partie logiciel que vous
allez retrouver vous avez plein de
contenus qui est classé les séries pride
la fête des pères film d'action vous
avez votre menu avec vos applications
pourraient venir installer désinstaller
comme vous le souhaitez c'est votre
catalogue d'applications vous avez
youtube disney + molotov my canal
spotify ocs 10 heures j'en passe et
compagnie vous en avez pas mal à vous de
voir ce qui vous intéresse selon vos
centres d'intérêt vous avez également
des jeux peut donc venir vous amuser
utiliser votre télé comme une petite
console et piloter tout ça grâce à votre
télécommande vous avez accès à vos
sources très facilement vos paramètres
vous avez un hymne à nu est si jamais
vous galérez depuis toutes vos
applications voulais retrouver elles
sont installées juste ici c'est très
simple c'est intuitif ça marche très
bien dans son élément tyson j'aime
beaucoup mais vous pouvez également
venir piloter votre télé grâce à
l'application smart things je la trouve
ici je peux contrôler ma télé peut
monter leçon baisser le songe en espèces
de paille pour bien choisir monter les
chaînes décédée chez elle j'ai pas mal
l'interface différent d'ailleurs à
l'installation votre téléviseur vous la
paramétrer grâce à smart sim vous faites
les premiers réglages de base la partie
au fait de tout ça parce qu'avoir un bel
écran bonne qualité d'image c'est bien
mais si le son n'est pas à la hauteur
ça serait un peu dommage ici on a
quelque chose qui fonctionne très bien
en termes de spatialisation surtout ont
navarro spect qui assez bien et si vous
voulez aller plus loin en termes
d'expérience pour vraiment apporté à de
plus de rondeur lorsque vous allez râler
des films d'action ou des grosses séries
science fiction ou voyez où ça vibre
vous n'avez pas l'emploi et sur cet
écran la télé marche très bien comme
elle est là mais si vous voulez aller
plus loin il vous faut une barre de son
samsung la proposition complètement
compatible mais attention et je vous le
dis ça fonctionne très bien la qualité
comme elle est là elle vraiment bien
vous avez une puissance totale de 70
watts vous avez pas moins de six haut
parleurs
parti un peu de partout et vous avez une
techno qui s'appelle au ts plus object
tracking sand plus il va y avoir une
reconnaissance du déplacement d'un objet
sur votre téléviseur vous allez entendre
ce que vous voyez vous le montre dans un
exemple vous voyez un bateau qui se
décale comme ça et bien le sont basses
décalé aussi cette télé de samsung va
venir apporter encore plus à l'immersion
il ya une autre techno qui est assez
intéressante c'est une amplification
vocal lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
bruits font ici par exemple c'est une
seule et même grande pièce vous avez ici
la partie salon mais vous avez la partie
cuisine qui est juste à côté donc
lorsque je suis en train de mixer en
train de cuisiner ou que je passe
l'aspirateur ou je ne sais quoi encore
outre si elliott par exemple regarde un
dessin animé à ce moment là et bien ça
veut dire l'embêter ce qu'ont fait un
petit peu usuellement on vient de monter
le son de la télé les approches trop
avec des volumes sonores absolument
incroyable donc je compte bien faire ici
votre télé elle via mesurer le bruit
ambiant et lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de
bruit elle vient réajuster les
fréquences au niveau de la voix pour
permettre à la voie de se détacher sans
forcément avoir besoin de monter le son
de la télé et lorsque le volume sonore
on va venir diminuer l avenir réajuster
en gwada me réajuster dynamiquement en
permanence vous avez votre assistant
intelligent avec vous soit bixby soit
amazon avec ça arrivera grâce à une mise
à jour ultérieure google assistant mais
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore le
cas mais peuvent venir ici brancher vos
appareils d'apple grâce à apple airplay
aujourd'hui ce téléviseur n'est pas
forcément fait pour tout le monde on
reste quand même sur un produit de niche
on restera un produit qui est très cher
bientôt marquer là dessus sur la version
65 pouces on est à 3999 euros ça reste
quand même un gros budget mais je dirais
que pour rentrer dans de l'a8 car
aujourd'hui c'est assez convenable mais
c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent pour
les d'accord là dessus
la version 75 pouces coûte 5499 il a un
garçon 82 pouces coûte 6000 999 euros il
ya une haute gamme huit cas chez samsung
ou encore coûte cher je vais pas dire
que c'est la gamme la plus abordable
même si quelque part ça les est ce que
maintenant il faut aller là dessus est
ce qu'il faut l'acheter c'est une
question très personnelle pour moi c'est
un produit qu'il a fait n'est plus aux
technophiles personnes qui veulent les
dernières innovations est ce qu'on a
besoin de huit cas aujourd'hui
non est ce que c'est un écran qui est
cool et qui est de bonne qualité qui
hyper agréable un marché soit oui alors
vous avez la place pour accueillir un
écran de minimum 65 pouces ça permet de
positionner samsung en tant que leader
sur les technologies innovantes les
nouvelles techno et notamment de la
guica qui n'est pas
encore prête pour tout le monde qui
n'est pas encore démocratisé la 4k n'est
pas encore complètement installé partout
les huit cas c'est pas pour tout de
suite c'est pour demain en tout cas
c'est un écran que j'apprécie et on re
découvre du contenu de ce restaurant et
regarder les dessins animés avec elliot
on re découvre les choses déjà dans un
très très grand écran avec une qualité
qui est vraiment au rendez vous
personnellement j'ai vraiment aimé
l'expérience de se produire d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse vous a mis un lien en
bas dans la description
maintenant il ya deux choses que je veux
dire un petit peu regretté le premier je
vous lis et où cette question du passage
de câbles qui sur un écran très très
haut de gamme c'est pas super finissent
pas super bien aboutie et deuxième point
mais ça il faut vraiment venir le faire
faut vraiment venir devant c'est que
c'est un écran qui dégage quand même pas
mal de chaleur je me mets la voyait ses
distances et je sens la chaleur surnomme
alors bon vous n'êtes pas bien vous
coller dessus souci temps d'ici là vous
avez froid vous vous rapprocher de votre
écran et je puis vous assurer que ça va
venir vous réchauffer voilà pour mes
retours sur ce dernier écran ucad
samsung personnellement je suis assez
enthousiaste la techno lucas se trouve
intéressante on n'y est pas encore mais
ça a permet d'aller encore plus loin en
termes de qualité d'image que ce soit
bien évidemment pour du visionnage de
films l'audio et bonne qualité mais si
vous voulez aller plus loin il faut
venir m une barre de son est si vous
allez mettre une telle somme sur une
télé comme ça on serait dommage de ne
pas aller plus loin en termes
d'expérience audio avec une barre de son
complètement adapté a vous de me dire
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce que vous
seriez prêts à acheter un téléviseur 8
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
solution nous propose son glas de cet
écran là est ce que vous trouvez
intéressant est ce que vous pourriez
franchir le pas ou est ce que vous
l'avez déjà franchi marque qui m'a tout
ça bien évidemment en bas en commentaire
quand on se retrouve très rapidement
pour continuer à parler tech également
parlé de téléviseurs beaucoup d'amour et
a très bien
[Musique]